freunde der sonne heute geht es um die
farmer verschwörung aus aktuellem anlass
bei unserem letzten video haben wir vor
dem bleichmittel aka heilmittel mms
gewarnt und voila die pharma-
verschwörung geht so die pharmaindustrie
will uns gar nicht heilen mit den
medikamenten die sie uns verkaufen für
viele krankheiten gibt es nämlich
einwandfreie und günstige therapien aber
die pharmaindustrie möchte nicht dass
wir davon erfahren warum werde damit sie
uns weiterhin mittelmäßige aber teure
medikamente verkaufen können die zwar
die symptome bekämpfen aber die
krankheit nicht vereinen wie sonst soll
die pharmaindustrie milliarden geschäft
machen gut durch die freunde der sonne
macht es euch möglich denn das wird
jetzt was erstmal nein ich werde nicht
von der pharmaindustrie bezahlt sondern
viel schlimmer vom rundfunkbeitrag ich
habe keinen persönlichen vorteil wenn
ich vor heilmitteln wie ms war zeigen
die öffentlich rechtlichen sind teil der
verschwörung okay die meisten von euch
sind freunde der sonne und denken sich
jetzt e health system sturm sein budget
aber habt ihr schon mal ernsthaft
versucht die pharma verschwörung zu
diskutieren zum beispiel mit ms
anwendern ich habe gesehen viele von
euch haben es in den kommentaren
versucht aber es ist gar nicht so
einfach
deshalb gibt es jetzt hier fünf
hilfestellungen erstens schlechte
medikamente schaffen es nicht auf den
markt medikamente und therapien sind
streng reguliert zuerst müssen sie im
labor getestet werden mit zell und hier
versuchen die sind die voraussetzung für
die klinischen studien mit menschen mit
hunderten von menschen die ebenfalls
durchgeführt werden müssen bevor ein
medikament überhaupt auf den markt
kommen kann
das ganze dauert viele jahre das ganze
ist auch ziemlich teuer
eine milliarde kosten aber wir können
froh sein dass dieser aufwand verlangt
wird denn es wäre absolut
unverantwortlich irgendein stoff für
medizinische zwecke zu verabreichen der
nicht sorgfältig durch klinische studien
geprüft wurde
zum unmut der medikamentenhersteller
führt dieser lange und teure prozess oft
gar nicht zu einem produkt an jeder
stelle des entwicklungsprozesses kann
man scheitern und damit viel geld und
arbeit in den sand setzen weil
medikamentenentwicklung nun einmal sehr
kompliziert ist weil der menschliche
körper und seine krankheiten sehr
kompliziert sind und selbst wenn man es
bis zum ende schafft zugelassen wird ein
medikament nur wenn es erstens wirkt
natürlich 2 die nebenwirkungen dabei
vertretbar sind und drittens wenn es in
irgendeiner hinsicht auch esser ist jung
keinen vorteil hat gegenüber den
medikamenten für die entsprechende
krankheit die bereits auf dem markt sind
durch diese regulierungen wird
entsprechend verhindert dass ein
skrupelloser geldgieriger pharmakonzern
ein unwirksames oder schädliches
präparat auf den markt bringt und da die
entwicklung der medikamente so teuer ist
und wie gesagt ohne erfolgsgarantie
während die konzerne ja schön blöd wenn
sie ein eigentlich viel besseres
heilmittel dem markt fern halten würden
übrigens eben weil medikamente so streng
kontrolliert werden findet man zb in der
nms szene ständig dieses klima wie
[Musik]
solche hinweise heißen übersetzt im
gegensatz zu einem medikament oder einer
medizinischen therapie wurde hier wieder
etwas belegt noch etwas kontrolliert
oder geprüft nummer zwei einfache
lösungen für schwer heilbare krankheiten
sind leider nicht realistisch die
heilung von krebs zum beispiel wird sehr
häufig bei solchen heilmitteln
versprochen okay zunächst ist krebs
biologisch höchst komplex und es gibt
auch nicht den krebs es gibt viele
verschiedene krebsarten denen alle
verschiedene biologische prozesse zu
grunde liegen und bei manchen krebsarten
ist die medizinische forschung schon
weit gekommen zum beispiel brustkrebs
denen können heute viele menschen
überwinden
warum die pharmaindustrie hier die
heilung nicht geheilt who knows andere
krebsarten wie bauchspeicheldrüsenkrebs
endet meist tödlich sowohl alle
expertinnen und experten die irgendwo
auf der welt zu krebs forschen als auch
der gesunde menschenverstand sprechen
dagegen dass etwas so komplexes wie zum
beispiel krebs durch eine ganz einfache
simple lösung zu bekämpfen ist also
diese ganzen heiler und gurus die haben
natürlich ihre behauptungen die
allerdings nicht plausibel sind und
ziemlich einfache wissenschaftlich zu
widerlegen sind wie zb unserem letzten
video gezeigt haben link in der info
karten reich nicht nur pharmafirmen
machen medizinische forschung ein
beliebtes gegenargument ist die
pharmafirmen bringen das nicht auf den
markt schweiz ist nicht patentieren
können nehmen wir mal spaßeshalber an
das bleichmittel chlordioxid würde
tatsächlich gegen krebs helfen
dann wäre es wirklich nicht ganz einfach
das zu patentieren zumindest müssten
sich die pharmafirmen etwas einfallen
lassen
ich denke zwar dass da was einfallen
würde aber prinzipiell kann man durchaus
sagen dass die pharmakonzerne kein
anreiz hätten viel geld für forschung
und entwicklung in die hand zu nehmen
wenn sie am ende das patent nicht sicher
haben aber wenn es wirklich ernst zu
nehmende hinweise gebe dass ein mitte
links eine revolutionäre durchbruch bei
der heilung an erkrankung werden
dann gibt es ja nicht nur die farmer
vieren die ganzen unis die
forschungseinrichtung auf der ganzen
welt alle in riesen interesse daran jede
forscherin und jeder forscher möchten
durch ein mittel gegen eine unheilbare
krankheit entdecken oder entwickeln oder
meinetwegen auch nur dessen medizinische
wirksamkeit wissenschaftlich belegen für
sowas werden nobelpreise verliehen und
für forschungsinteressen die nicht
wirtschaftlich sind gibt es unter
anderem so sachen wie die gates
foundation die zum beispiel malaria
forschung unterstützt weil die sich für
konzerne finanziell nicht rechnet und
genau so wäre es zb auch bei mms
wenn da nur irgend etwas wahres dran
wäre was es hat nur leider nicht ist
nummer vier es gibt nicht die
pharmaindustrie also es gibt natürlich
die pharmaindustrie aber die besteht aus
vielen verschiedenen firmen die alle
miteinander in konkurrenz stehen anstatt
jetzt ein wundermittel also ein mittel
das zum beispiel alle krebsarten halt
für sich zu behalten würde ein konzern
natürlich viel mehr geld verdienen wenn
er dieses wundermittel einfach auf den
markt bringen würde der konzern wird
sich sofort in monopolstellung begeben
weil dieses mittel dann auch viel besser
wäre als alles was bisher auf dem markt
ist deswegen könnten sie ist schön teuer
an sehr sehr viele menschen verkaufen
wenn man jetzt trotzdem glaubt dass alle
unter einer decke stecken
da muss man diesen gedanken auch logisch
zu ende denken denn selbst wenn alle
pharmafirmen dem wettbewerb entsagt und
sich gemeinsam verschworen hätten
würde der plan noch lange nicht aufgehen
nummer fünf eine pharma verschwörung
müsste viel viel größer sein wie gesagt
die pharmaindustrie wird streng
reguliert wer das nicht glaubt muss
logischerweise folgern dass auch die
regulierungsbehörden mit den konzernen
unter einer decke stecken aber nicht nur
dass alle ärzte und krankenhäuser
müssten da irgendwie mit drin stecken
sowie auch alle unis und
forschungseinrichtungen die der welt die
medizinische forschung betreiben
außerdem alle mich hat der medizin auch
die voller lügen
da steht zum beispiel nur darin dass
autismus eigentlich heilbar ist und auch
alle journalisten die wie ich darüber
berichten müssten ja entweder mit unter
der decke stecken oder völlig geblendet
sein und obwohl es für journalisten
karrieretechnisch nichts besseres gibt
als einen riesigen skandal zu
veröffentlichen wurde bisher noch nichts
von dieser pharma verschwörung
aufgedeckt und alle diese vielen
menschen die teil dieser verschwörung
sind müssten ja eigentlich kerngesund
sein sagen wir es gebe ein geheimnis
mittel gegen krebs
dann würden hier alle menschen die teil
dieser verschwörung sind und deren
familien niemals krebs bekommen denn sie
würden dies mit doch hoffentlich
wenigstens für sich selbst nutzen oder
oder würden sie um die verschwörung zu
schützen sich selbst und ihre
familienmitglieder opfern
ok auf der anderen seite gibt es
menschen die heilmittel bewerten die so
gut wie keine kontrolle unterliegen
deren wirksamkeit nicht wissenschaftlich
belegt ist und doch schreibt sie bücher
bieten seminare an therapiesitzungen und
so weiter um geld zu verdienen moment
mal an könnte man ja fast meinen dass
diese heiler nur behaupten dass ihre
mittel wirken um mit den hoffnungen
ängsten von menschen mit schweren
krankheiten mit geld zu verdienen aber
was davon ist jetzt realistischer bitte
versucht
nachzudenken freunde der sonne ihr
werdet in den kommentaren zum beispiel
unter unserem mms video aber auch an
vielen anderen stellen im netz immer
wieder auch das argument der pharma
verschwörung stoßen nämlich immer wenn
es um sogenannte runde heilmittel
hingeht
in zukunft könnte euch einfach zeit und
mühe spart und als antwort einfach
dieses video posten